i
ah
[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález venezuela
fue a las urnas para unas elecciones
locales y estatales que le dieron la
victoria al oficialismo en las
gobernaciones de 20 de los 23 estados y
también en caracas la capital así como
más de 200 alcaldías a lo largo y ancho
del país por parte de la oposición
consiguieron las gobernaciones de nueva
esparta zulia y cojedes los comicios
contaron con un amplio ausentismo y
dejan nuevamente muchas dudas sobre la
articulación de los partidos de la
oposición y da para analizar qué tan
fortalecidos se mantiene el peso del
partido oficialista pero sobre todo da
para analizar el sistema electoral
venezolano su transparencia y la
independencia de las instituciones en
ese país veamos el siguiente informe
para entrar en contexto
--resultados el chavismo afianza su
poder en venezuela el presidente nicolás
maduro celebró los resultados de las
elecciones regionales del domingo en las
que se eligieron más de 3000 gobernantes
alcaldías y ayuntamientos de las 24
entidades federales del país el gran
polo patriótico las fuerzas
revolucionarios hemos ganado 21 e
incluyendo la capital de la república
bolivariana de venezuela caracas de 24
buen triunfo por su parte los rivales
del partido socialista unido de
venezuela ganaron solamente en los
estados de cojedes zulia y nueva esparta
para el opositor juan guaidó estos
comicios mostraron apatía por parte de
los ciudadanos con un abstencionismo de
casi el 60 por ciento
con un régimen de
rave y legítimo no solamente sino
también en desempeño señalado por
delitos de lesa humanidad agresor
amanece con 124 por eso pero algunos
críticos aseguran que la falta de unión
entre opositores y la carencia de
mensajes claros motivaron el ausentismo
además en caracas muchos dudan de la
transparencia del reciente proceso y
realmente yo pienso que eso fue trampa
nuevamente pues o sea no hay otra y yo
veo difícil que salgamos de esto sino si
nosotros los venezolanos pues no tomamos
otra acción pues porque esto ya todo el
mundo en todos lados y por ejemplo
venezuela quejándose de que no hay no no
hay gas no hay agua la gasolina
pero entonces en estos momentos ve que
todos que apoyan al gobierno los
resultados de las regionales son un
nuevo revés para la oposición luego de
boicotear las elecciones presidenciales
en 2018 y las elecciones al congreso en
ya lo veíamos el presidente nicolás
maduro se refirió a esta jornada
electoral celebró estos resultados que
son favorables para su partido dijo que
esto había sido gracias al arduo trabajo
y también a la honestidad tras un
acuerdo alcanzado en la mesa de diálogo
entre el gobierno y la oposición en
ciudad de méxico fue pactado realizar
estas elecciones y el gobierno de
nicolás maduro permitió una delegación
de observadores de la unión europea que
estaba encabezada por la portuguesa por
la diputada portuguesa isabel santos que
presentó las conclusiones de esta
jornada electoral escuchemos
las elecciones regionales y municipales
del 21 de noviembre fueran una primera y
crucial prueba para el regreso de la
mayoría de los partidos de oposición a
la competición electoral en venezuela
las elecciones se han fundamentado en
mejores condiciones en comparación con
procesos electorales entre ellos el
consello consejo electoral nacional que
fue renovado en mayo de 2021 es visto
como la administración electoral más
equilibrada que ha tenido venezuela en
los últimos 20 años nuestra misión ha
podido constatar la falta de
independencia judicial la no adherencia
al estado de derecho ahí lo ven santos
hizo referencias a lo positivo a lo
negativo que deja esta jornada electoral
y por supuesto entonces nos quedan
muchas preguntas para analizar qué
reflexión deja este proceso electoral en
venezuela qué análisis se puede hacer
del desempeño tanto del oficialismo como
del
qué se puede decir de la presencia de
observadores internacionales fue una
garantía suficiente para que hayan sido
equilibrados y transparentes que decir
entonces de las conclusiones de este
informe que veíamos que presentó la
observarla el grupo de observadores de
la unión europea que viene entonces para
venezuela después de este proceso
electoral para analizar este tema hemos
invitado a omar gonzález moreno él es
diputado de la asamblea nacional de
venezuela y también es miembro de la
dirección del partido
20 venezuela él se encuentra en la
ciudad de barcelona en el estado de
anzoátegui y también está con nosotros
william benavides él es diputado de la
asamblea nacional de venezuela por el
movimiento tupamaro está en la ciudad de
caracas la capital venezolana y aquí en
el estudio de france 24 está con
nosotros natasha rojas ella docente en
relaciones internacionales de la
pontificia universidad javeriana de la
ciudad de bogotá ciudadana venezolana y
está con nosotros aquí para analizar
este panorama electoral en ese país
ustedes también nuestros televidentes
pueden participar en este debate con
todas las preguntas y comentarios que
ustedes deciden dejar a través de las
redes sociales no se encuentran en
facebook en instagram y en twitter
estamos como france24 bajo ese arroba
sant y luego mi cuenta personal nuestra
etiqueta es numeral del debate efe 24
esperamos todos sus comentarios y sus
preguntas comienzo entonces con omar en
la ciudad de barcelona en el estado
anzoátegui sobre el balance general que
usted hace de esta jornada en un
escenario político por supuesto muy
complejo ya lo sabemos cuál es la
situación en venezuela se suma también
una compleja situación sanitaria y
económica
buenas noches santiago muchas gracias
por estar
abierto a escuchar las distintas
opiniones sobre este evento que no se
puede llamar 'selección esta fue una
simulación un teatro una pantomima un
circo montado por el régimen de nicolás
maduro precisamente en la búsqueda
desesperada de legitimar su mandato que
no es tampoco legítimo él está usurpando
la presidencia de la república porque es
producto de un fraude cometido hace dos
años atrás la posición de los
venezolanos fue una posición digna una
posición de rebeldía de rechazo a esa
farsa ese fraude porque más del 70 se
calcula que el 80 por ciento de los
venezolanos no fueron
a esa convocatoria a ese rechazo de
manera que los venezolanos nos da risa
cuando vemos a un nervioso en nicolás
maduro sobre quien pesa la posibilidad
de una condena a la corte penal
internacional por crímenes
gravísimos contra la humanidad cometidos
en venezuela diciendo y alardeando haber
ganado unas elecciones que no son no
fueron tales fue una simulación de
elecciones los venezolanos dieron una
demostración de dignidad si yo mal
rechazar de manera tan contundente esta
está este teatro esta pantomima si en
caracas william benavídez su balance de
esta jornada electoral regional y
estatal en venezuela
buenas noches gracias nuevamente por la
invitación gracias no extraordinario es
realmente para nosotros es una victoria
contundente
miren la movilización extraordinaria a
pesar de todo el tema de las condiciones
en venezuela 41 por ciento de
participación para nosotros es
extraordinario es excelente es muy bueno
el nivel de participación que se dio
nosotros tenemos que recordar que en el
proceso electoral nuestro uno está en
las mismas condiciones que cualquier
otro país nuestro país está siendo
bloqueado a sería sancionado con todas
unas condiciones de persecución
financiero internacional por supuesto
cuando se dice de la participación de
sectores la oposición mira todos los
partidos estuvieron en todo el programa
en consejo nacional electoral como
revisando cómo va a ser el proceso
electoral sus auditorías todo su proceso
de contabilización y por supuesto
el día viernes va otro proceso de
auditoría o sea y los con todos los
observadores internacionales
revisando todo el proceso eleccionario
por supuesto bueno nosotros tuvimos una
gran victoria
20 gobernaciones de 23 la capital bueno
y toda una victoria más de 200
alcaldías en todo el despliegue de
concejales y diputados regionales por
supuesto que suman todo un trabajo del
chavismo que suman todo el trabajo del
movimiento revolucionario de el polo
patriótico sí ya que en el estudio de
france 24 a natasha sus impresiones
sobre este esta jornada electoral bueno
creo que por un lado no fue un proceso
en absoluto exitoso para nada
democrático pero eso no quiere decir que
en contextos autoritarios no se puedan
dar este tipo de procesos sólo que se
conocen como elecciones no competitivas
y alguna u otra forma las condiciones
estaban dadas para poder dar ese proceso
electoral tener unos resultados que eran
esperables como los que se dieron
ciertamente si hubo más abstención que
lo que tradicionalmente
acciones legislativas las elecciones
legislativas las elecciones
territoriales en venezuela digamos que
porque generalmente este 40% se compara
con el resto de la región o incluso se
compara con colombia y es donde se cree
que es una cifra regular pero para el
caso venezolano esto no es para el caso
venezolano en el contexto en el que se
está en los últimos 20 años las
autoridades locales son sumamente
importantes y creo que para él fue
incluso una mayor sorpresa para el mismo
oficialismo la poca participación que
tuvieron incluso tienen candidatos que
volvieron a ganar algunos algunos
municipios y algunos estados con menos
votos con los que habían ganado nos en
ocasiones anteriores creo que hay mucho
que pensar sobre ese proceso y darse
cuenta que estamos en entrante un
autoritarismo y que este tipo de
procesos si se podría participar pero
reconociendo las limitantes y para qué
son si bueno tenemos el panorama general
de los tres invitados quiero pasar ahora
a preguntarle a william hago la ronda la
inversa
esto sin duda alguna lo veíamos en el
reportaje previo al debate que es era
una prueba de fuego para el sistema
electoral deben la que está muy
desacreditado a nivel internacional por
haber inhabilitado a varios partidos o
candidatos en escenarios electorales en
el pasado pero isabel santos la diputada
portuguesa que encabeza esta delegación
de la unión europea que estuvo allí como
observadores dijo que este consejo
nacional electoral fue calificado como
el más equilibrado en los últimos 20
años que reflexionase usted al respecto
sobre esta prueba de fuego que tenía el
sistema electoral venezolano
mira en todos los procesos extraerle se
ha llevado el mismo cronograma ya se
hace una revisión se hace una auditoría
yo creo que no hay otro sistema en el
mundo más transparente que el sistema
venezolano todo el proceso de auditoría
que se lleva cómo se lleva hay otros
países y no los mencionan que después
del proceso electoral después que se
hagan las elecciones duran hasta dos o
tres semanas para decir quién ganó o
anunciar es que aquí no en el caso
venezolano no en el caso venezolano e
inmediatamente hay un proceso de
contabilización es decir es por ejemplo
que mira que en una dictadura como haya
ese proceso electoral tiene que
reconocer venezuela es un país
democrático y la oposición cuando pierde
nos reconoce las elecciones y cuando
ganan entonces van un proceso
conspirativo de golpe de estado entonces
cómo se explican que hace en el período
legislativo pasado esa oposición
alcanzar mayoría en una asamblea
nacional se embriagaron de una victoria
y se fueron fue hacia el elemento
conspirativo hace un golpe estado como
es que ahorita se explica que ganan tres
gobernaciones y una de esas
gobernaciones es importantísimo está una
importante parte de la población
venezolana que el estado zulia igual y
el reconocimiento a todas esas fuerzas
que participaron como se explica que la
oposición gana varias alcaldías a nivel
nacional ganan varios concejales
diputados regionales creo que ese doble
discurso de la oposición o de un sector
de la oposición tratando de buscar
pescar en ríos revueltos o buscar
cualquier elemento que en tu vida o
tratando de hacer un discurso para
agradar a una parte de la comunidad
internacional está muy mal porque a que
mereció no dejar muy mal parado será no
es la realidad venezolana venezuela
vivió su proceso democrático todos esos
partidos fueron a todos los procesos de
y si nosotros podemos mostrar toda la
gente nosotros este servidor como
secretario general de un partido un
tupamaro del polo participamos en todos
los procesos previos a las elecciones y
por supuesto que brinda los logros los
veedores internacionales la admisión
internacional y va a revisar todo el
proceso y sigue siendo el mismo proceso
electoral sigue el mismo proceso que
hemos vivido durante los últimos 20 años
varios antes de estar michelle yo
tratando de ganar adeptos con mentiras
hagamos análisis gris hagamos análisis
sincero y hablemos la realidad
venezolana hubo 40 por ciento si es 41
por ciento de participación pero un país
asediado un país bloqueado y perseguido
un país permanentemente desarrollado
internacionalmente y con todo una gran
agresión mediática williams y yo le
preguntaba por la prueba de fuego que da
para el sistema electoral no la posición
de la oposición sobre el sistema
electoral venezolano pero pero valida la
respuesta omar su opinión al respecto
bueno en primer lugar en cuba en rusia
en nicaragua hay simulaciones de
procesos como el que vimos este domingo
en venezuela
y el mundo lo ha condenado incluso hasta
personas que están vinculadas con la
izquierda como es la presidenta o la
coordinadora de la observación de la
unión europea es bueno en su informe
destaca que en venezuela no hay un poder
judicial independiente
es bueno que la gente que sigue tu
programa de santiago se entere que en
venezuela como nicaragua este fueron
inhabilitados los principales líderes
políticos fueron secuestrados los
partidos políticos pasados entregados
como si fueran barajitas a afectos al
régimen los principales partidos
políticos fueron utilizados los
efectivos militares para que a punta de
fusil sacaran a los miembros y testigos
de algunos de los que participaban en
esta farsa que los llamados colectivos
que son pandillas paramilitares acosaban
hostigaban a las personas que de buena
fe creían que éste era un proceso
electoral y no una simulación electoral
además el ventajismo la censura de los
medios de comunicación ese mismo día
fueron 16 periodistas
agredidos además de la censura muchos
medios de comunicación colombianos que
fueron sacados a empellones de los
centros electorales
así como también desde luego en
venezuela no existen en medios
independientes porque hay una crisis
censura incluso hasta el informe de la
comisión de observadores pudieron
destacaron gramos evidencia el uso
descarado de los recursos públicos para
favorecer a los candidatos del
oficialismo en esta farsa electoral
porque no podemos permitir que se hable
de un proceso electoral en venezuela no
hubo elecciones si hubo un circo
precisamente para legitimar la
usurpación de nicolás maggi omar
compinches que están a punto de ser
juzgado internacionalmente por delitos
de lesa humanidad les pido por favor a
los invitados que respondan más puntual
porque se me va el tiempo el programa y
me tengo que pasar el tiempo pidiéndoles
que corten que corten entonces por favor
sean más puntuales natasha su balance de
esta puesta a prueba de fuego para el
sistema electoral venezolano hay algunas
críticas algunos comentarios por parte
de estos observadores internacionales ya
lo veíamos lo hemos mencionado cuál es
su análisis
bueno como bien mencionas están ahí las
críticas específicamente un tema
fundamental que es el poder judicial y
es algo en lo que hay que ponerle
mira de cerca pero la dificultad que
tienen precisamente estas misiones
electorales es que la observación la
hacen del proceso en ese momento no
todas las cosas que suceden antes del
proceso electoral y eso es precisamente
lo que pasa en esta ocasión parte de la
oposición cuando toma la decisión que
ésta no es la ruta para una transición
en venezuela le hace el proceso es mucho
más sencillo al oficialismo no tienen
que hacer traslado de votantes como
tradicionalmente se hacía no tienen que
tener como estos temas turbios sobre
conteo de votos entonces eso permite
mostrar de la comunidad internacional
que es un proceso aparentemente más
transparente pero lo que hay que mirar
aquí es lo que pasó anterior al proceso
en la invalidación de los partidos la
inhabilitación de las personas que
participaban el uso de los medios de
comunicación y como captaron todos los
medios e incluso como bloquearon
portales digitales y como no dieron
credenciales a los periodistas para que
pudiesen reportar lo que estaba
sucediendo
natalia sigo con usted que en el estudio
de france 24 le preguntó por el
desempeño de la oposición que era muy
significativo que regresara a participar
en estos comicios
logra tres gobernaciones pero sigue
quedando en evidencia esa fragmentación
que en el interior de los diferentes
partidos de oposición que balance hace
usted del desempeño algo que es claro y
es la unidad no significa que toda la
oposición tenga que pensar por igual y
aquí hay que pensarse en oposiciones no
hechas para una democracia donde pueden
haber diferentes sectores que piensen
completamente diferente sino aquí es una
sola intencionalidad transitar a la
democracia y para eso se necesita que la
oposición se una y lo segundo creo que
la oposición debería entender que todas
las vías son válidas cuando se quiere
apuntar a ese objetivo no se le puede
poner o no se le puede apostar sólo a
una sola vía porque ya se han hecho esos
intentos y han fracasado y por este lado
aquí en la ciudad de barcelona en el
estado anzoátegui omar su balance del
desempeño de la de los partidos
opositores ya lo mencionaba tres
gobernaciones es significativo para
ellos william destacaba que uno de estos
estados es el estado zulia un estado
petrolero que concentra una buena parte
de la población está una de las ciudades
más importantes de venezuela maracaibo
es significativo a usted cómo lo ve
el rechazo que se demostró el pasado
domingo
una posición de rebeldía de dignidad del
pueblo venezolano al no prestarse esta
farsa no solamente fue contra el régimen
de nicolás maduro y sus compinches
sino también a una oposición que se ha
doblegado unos líderes oposición entre
comillas que se han rendido en la lucha
contra la tiranía incluso están
cohabitando y han sacado
beneficios crematísticos y de otra
naturaleza desde esa cohabitación de
manera que el rechazo ha sido hacia el
maduro y su camarilla así como también a
esa oposición que se rindió pero la
inmensa mayoría de los venezolanos más
del
70% de los venezolanos se mantienen
fieles a la lucha por alcanzar la
libertad y eso se va a ver en los
próximos días este domingo se cerró un
ciclo político no estuvieron a la altura
quienes están dirigiendo la oposición en
venezuela de las circunstancias
históricas
de destrucción que está viviendo nuestro
país y está exigiendo y necesitando una
nueva conducción política que en el
juicio de muchos de nosotros le encarna
una mujer maría corina machado es lo que
desde abajo hacia arriba grita el pueblo
venezolano que asuma la conducción de la
oposición venezolana porque alguna mujer
con coraje con inteligencia y con
decisión para enfrentar un régimen
tiránico como el de nicolás maduro
william le pregunto por el oficialismo
usted ya destacaba alguno de los logros
en estas elecciones pero vale la pena
mencionar que la votación por el psuv y
por la coalición que conforman los
partidos que están cercanos al gobierno
bajó de 5.6 millones en elecciones
regionales del 2017 a 3.7 millones que
le dice a usted esto qué reflexión hacen
de esta pérdida de votos
bueno uno tenemos que realizar
normalmente un proceso de flujo y
reflujo en todos los procesos políticos
es dialécticos solo tenemos que revisar
cómo ha sido nuestra gobernanza como
hacia el proceso de gobierno los
liderazgos locales el proceso del poder
popular todo eso nosotros
permanentemente lo estamos revisando en
el caso de nuestra organización nosotros
subimos casi que el 100 por ciento
nosotros en ese proceso hemos sacado 100
mil votos mientras estamos 210 mil votos
en un proceso incremento importante de
un liderazgo que está ahí surgiendo de
una juventud que está montada no está en
su tarea nosotros creemos profundamente
que hay que revisar estadísticamente
número número lógicamente cada proceso
los liderazgos que se están construyendo
que se están desarrollando en cada
región por supuesto que es parte del
análisis electoral pero es importante
repetir no estamos viviendo un proceso
electoral en un país con todas las
condiciones normales son 40 por ciento
de participación en un país que está
permanentemente hace días que está
bloqueo económicamente y sancionado y
perseguido financieramente
ante eso inyectado unión la unión
europea precisamente william el
secretario de estado de eeuu anthony
blinken señaló a través de un comunicado
de prensa que estas elecciones fueron
irregulares el régimen de maduro privó
una vez más a los venezolanos de su
derecho a participar en un proceso
electoral libre y justo durante estas
elecciones regionales y locales que dice
usted al respecto
no vale yo creo que es desconocimiento
nosotros invitamos así como invitamos a
esta comisión de la unión europea como
observadores a todos los que quisieran
venir en todos los procesos electorales
a todo que quieran venir no están así es
un discurso trillado de un sector de la
oposición que permanentemente cuando
pierde dice que el árbitro no es bueno
pero es como un juego de fútbol y si el
ámbito que invita a cualquier falta si
no te gusta el árbitro ya es así en el
proceso venezolano esa oposición
permanentemente en las veces que ha
perdiéndose bueno llama la violencia
llama el asesinato llaman un golpe de
estado pero no reconocen a su propio
liderazgo interno nosotros no
pretendemos resolver
pero yo no le estoy hablando de
representantes de la oposición le estoy
hablando del secretario de estado de
eeuu anthony blinken que es el
representante de la diplomacia eeuu que
se refiere a este proceso varios países
han mencionado estos comicios a nivel
internacional
eeuu estaba presionando y colombia el
gobierno de colombia abiertamente para
crack para que se parara el sector de la
oposición que estaba conversando en
mexico en la mesa de diálogo en médico
lo estaba presionando permanentemente
seguía un diplomático venezolano de cabo
verde para hacer presión en ese sector
no les interesa para ello una democracia
es cuando los beneficia a ellos tienen
que respetar la soberanía y la
autodeterminación de todos los pueblos
porque cuando los favorece si es bueno
el proceso electoral el árbitro pero
cuando no lo favorece no es bueno si
will yo creo que debemos respetar ese
doble ración esa doble moral
pasó a preguntarle aquí en el estudio de
france 24 en la talla sobre ese
significativo 41 8% de participación la
abstención fue la protagonista de esta
jornada que balance hacia usted bueno
creo que no responde en su totalidad y
de hecho esta vez sucede en su totalidad
no corresponde sólo a una posición
política el oficialismo también pierde
votos en este proceso de abstención aquí
juegan muchos elementos
yo fue la falta de información esta vez
con esta edad de lo que se llama al voto
cruzado el voto entubado las formas de
votación la gente no tenía conocimiento
por primera vez el cnn no daba
suficiente información de cómo tenían
que actuar las personas quedan miembros
de mesa es decir la desinformación jugó
un rol fundamental sobre el proceso el
desánimo y la desconfianza pero aquí sí
quiero resaltar una cosa dentro de las
últimas encuestas y las mediciones que
se hace en venezuela resulta algo
paradójico la mayoría de los venezolanos
ha perdido la esperanza de una salida
electoral pero cuando les preguntan cuál
creen que sería el mejor mecanismo creen
que es un proceso democrático electoral
es decir el venezolano en su esencia no
quiere violencia no quiere
intervenciones quiere esto pero no
confía en el proceso que hay incluso con
el cambio los rectores del cn
manifestaron que no confiaban en este
árbitro y eso es fundamental para
participar en un proceso electoral y
también hay que sumarle el contexto en
el que estamos de la pandemia de kobe 19
que venezuela le ha costado mucho
también pues como a todos los países de
la región hacer frente a esta situación
y genera también miedo entre los
ciudadanos salir votar exponerse salir a
hacer las filas y estar allí en los
centros de votación ya me quedan pocos
minutos para finalizar el programa
quiero preguntarle a omar en la ciudad
de barcelona sobre lo que sigue para
venezuela en términos políticos a partir
de estos comicios usted dice que esto
fue el cierre de un capítulo y el inicio
de otro a nivel político entonces que
sigue para este país
efectivamente
se inicia una nueva etapa y pasan a
retiro
dirigentes que no he estado a la altura
de las circunstancias y de venezuela y
una nueva conducción política se avisora
en el horizonte
sobre las
este fue el evento más
cuestionado de la historia no solamente
fue el secretario de estado
norteamericano el que ha señalado las
irregularidades cometidas acaba de
pronunciarse canadá desde luego colombia
la propia de brasil y las democracias
más importantes del mundo no reconoce
incluso llamas este es el evento más
cuestionado en la historia política de
venezuela en los últimos años de manera
porque hasta la propia escogencia del
poder electoral de los miembros del
consejo
nacional electoral fue y rita fue
espuria porque la escogió una asamblea
nacional espuria ilegítima producto de
un fraude del 6 de diciembre otros
fraudes electoral ustedes me dijera a mí
que nicaragua es igualito a cuba cuba
hacer elecciones todos los años este
creen que hay democracia en cuba usted
cree que hay democracia en nicaragua en
lukashenko hay hambre bielorrusia en una
democracia esto es peor que esos países
aquí lo que hay es una tiranía que las
tiranías
llaman a elecciones para perderlas y si
no pierdan las arrebata como es lo que
ha sucedido inverso y pasarle la palabra
a william en la ciudad de caracas
william sus conclusiones que sigue para
su país que sigue para venezuela
mira para nosotros siguen mucho trabajo
mucho trabajo proceso nosotros de
trabajar mucho
de seguir fortaleciendo
es el proceso de soberanía alimentaria
de trabajar mucho los bienes y los
servicios para la población del trabajo
de la mano del poder popular de
desarrollar nuestra tesis política creo
que eso es lo que viene para nosotros en
el caso de los próximos procesos
electorales nosotros invitamos a toda la
comunidad internacional que vengan sus
observadores internacionales a nosotros
eso no nos preocupa como organizaciones
revolucionarias como un movimiento
revolucionario lo que sí quedan de
reconocer un árbitro bueno hay un sector
de los cuestión que no reconoce ese es
su problema y hay rectores que son
abiertamente vinculados estas sectores
de la oposición pero creo que nosotros
tenemos que el reconocimiento el árbitro
gane quien gane y lo otro en el caso de
chávez no seguir trabajando nosotros
seguimos desarrollando mientras nuestra
tesis política tiene mucho trabajo son
20 gobernaciones de estados que ha
ganado el oficialismo allí en venezuela
natacha la conclusión que sigue para
este país en términos políticos y
sabiendo que quedan dos estados barinas
y apure todavía por saber los resultados
definitivos de quienes ganan allí la
elección de gobernación yo quisiera
destacar tres puntos en el futuro
cercano sobre la política venezolana el
primero y que independientemente de las
pocas garantías que hubo las
inexistentes garantías ese es el tablero
que queda y que ese tablero no
representa necesariamente las afinidades
y el sentir de los venezolanos eso es lo
primero lo segundo creo que debemos
esperar como actuó en estos partidos que
dicen llamarse oposición que
participaron a ver qué tan oposición son
o qué tan leales son el oficialismo y
esto marcaría que están que tanto cubre
la unidad y ya al determinar quiénes
conforman esa unidad la oposición se
encuentra en este tercer punto que
quiero resaltar ante un posible
escenario que empiezan a discutir y van
a apuntar a un proceso revocatorio y tal
vez desgastar a la población en ese
proceso o ya se van a empezar a
organizar para un posible proceso en las
presidenciales creo que esos son tres
puntos fundamentales en este momento me
queda un minuto para hacerle otra
pregunta en una talla y es sobre la
comunidad internacional que reacciones
puede haber por parte de la comunidad
internacional ya que se han empezado a
conocer estos informes de los
observadores donde anuncian algunas
irregularidades destacan algunos avances
pero hay algunos otros puntos que
todavía tienen por delante para mejorar
aún está por darse a conocer otros
informes como el del centro cárter y el
de la misión de la organización de
naciones unidas que puede pasar entonces
otra vez estamos ante un no
reconocimiento de unas votaciones o como
lo de usted y aunque el proceso local o
regional tiene pero otro impacto a nivel
de la comunidad internacional y es muy
importante lo que está sucediendo porque
tal vez el oficialismo particularmente
maduro más que los poderes locales
estaba jugando la legitimidad
internacional y quiero que estos
pronunciamientos son fundamentales para
que la comunidad internacional no se
confunda y sepa que en venezuela no hay
una democracia es un autoritarismo que
es competitivo y por eso hace elecciones
pero que las condiciones no están dadas
para para poder dialogar de manera
directa y democrática con el rey tener
elecciones periódicas una autoridad
electoral y un sistema moderno tal
parece que no garantiza que sea un
proceso democrático así quedan las cosas
después de este análisis a los tres
invitados a omar a william ya natasha
que en el estudio de france 24 les
agradezco por haber estado con nosotros
por haber compartido con nosotros y
nuestra audiencia sus opiniones sobre
este tema ustedes pueden seguir dejando
sus comentarios y sus preguntas a través
de las redes sociales de france 24 a mi
cuenta personal pueden seguir también en
compañía de la programación de france 24
5 con nosotros buenas noches
[Música]